[Music]
hello my name is orlando louis pardo
i'm a chess instructor and i have been
working with the chess club and
scholastic center since
2019 i teach scouts and
also elementary secondary and colleges
yeah when i started i was traveling all
around the city
from school to school different
neighborhoods different different areas
of the city that i didn't know
i am from havana cuba so i have been
living in san luis for
only four years and it was a way of also
understanding
the city and suddenly this year after
the social distances and everything that
started well it has been very different
because basically i'm at my place
every day facing the same computer but
still trying to bring to those kids
the imagination creativity the desire to
play
to understand the game zoom up allows us
to do a video conference a video call
so i'm able to start talking to the kids
all of the kids can see me i can see
them
then i can share the screen so i can
explain
in a with a chess playing
website like liches or chess.com
especially leeches is the one that we're
using
i explain to them a number of notions
and they can only
listen and watch what i'm doing but then
i invite them to share their
screens too so they can also explain to
me back or
discuss some questions that they may
have but then
i invite them to play a tournament in
real time they cannot play
using the zoom app you cannot play chess
by using skype for example you know
so we need to also shift this
internet the browser tab to the
liches.org
website they need to have an account
created
on alice.org it's a safe website but
you can even create special accounts for
children
and then once that you have an account
everybody is logged in we go to a second
tab
i keep sharing the screen and then there
we start playing a tournament
so they are we are really using two
internet
tools zoom and then liches and we are
playing on real time while i keep
talking
giving some instructions some tutoring
games guiding comments
jokes uh during the tournament so
they and they at the same time they talk
to me during the tournament sometimes a
little noisy and then i say please
respectfully muting everybody so that we
could concentrate in the game
because they but they are at the same
time they are learning you know to be
polite to be gentle with it it would be
nice with the opponent
they they learn very early on even if
they get frustrated when they lose a
game say
good game good game next time we'll be
different yes but good game right now
and and
wishing each other good luck we want to
win
but we want to win playing chess we the
opponent we need the opponent otherwise
we wouldn't be able to play
we wouldn't be able to win we wouldn't
be able to lose or to make a
hard-fought draw so the idea that we
need to reach out for others
that the the other person is there maybe
in our living room
and we need to respect each other and
keep civility
the conversation going on i'm very
frustrated today i lost my first three
games
still i'm happy we are in a community
next day maybe we'll be better
and if it's not going better it's
because you're doing something wrong and
if you're doing something wrong we can
work on that
to try to make it not wrong anymore to
try to make it right so it's a very
nice and constructive idea and
use the internet to teach chess and
learn chess
only in other areas of internet maybe
there is a lot of
battleground going on but in the case of
chess the battleground
goes to the chess pieces no and then
people to people is a nice engagement
i feel that when i am teaching online
and also learning online from my
students
[Music]